[Music]
hello Malek it's lovely to see you back
in Saint Louis and it's in general
lovely to see you
so as a captain of our Women's National
Chess team do you feel like you need to
play tournaments to feel don't to not
lose the feeling of a player yes
absolutely you know that I always
thought uh in order for me to kind of
provide high quality service
particularly for U.S national team I
thought I need to have some still
practical strength and that's the reason
why I'm still pushing myself even so I
don't have much time I can be occupied
with lessons but still I suppose I have
a window I'm jumping on it and I'm
trying to play some tournaments make
sure I can still keep my kind of
strength on it you know absolutely and
you got a wild card for this tournament
what does it mean to you honestly didn't
realize it's wild card sure when Alex
told me that by the way it's like a few
minutes ago
I'm sure I was surprised I was shocked
but uh I checked my emails always
frequently and as soon as I saw like
email from Saint Louis I like jumped
from the chair I said oh my gosh really
this is what I was playing for the
funniest part I began so I got some
invitations to play in some tournaments
but I always reply to my you know
friends saying listen I'm hoping to
qualify for you a sinner I'm hoping to
qualify for you sooner because for me
the Saint Louis as destination always
considered as a top priority so I was
hoping for it and I guess got so you
manifested it
pretty much here that is awesome
see you playing as well for me because
you usually uh you were our captain for
the Olympiad as well and usually you
just you know help us with the
tournament and I'm happy to see you
suffering a little bit as well as a
chess player and what are your
expectations around the tournament
honestly I'm here to play chess
I think two years ago after pandemic
when I came here I had a high
expectation I thought I'm ready to fight
uh for the you know high place blah blah
blah so I got lost place
I Said So Daddy goes to the tournaments
nothing goes will happen it would happen
two years ago so this time it's going to
be fun right and I'm just here to play
chess and I'll do my best so we'll see
awesome and a last question for you
how do you handle to be a captain in
general like just sit there and see your
team and then your you have great
students as well as a coach to see how
they are playing do you get a feeling
you just want to sit instead of them and
just make moves
it's it's it's yeah you you nail it um
basically This Is My Philosophy that's
why I believe
I'm kind of sucking all this negative
energy
and I'm reversing it to negative I mean
to positive and I'm sending my wives to
my girls to you to everyone and I think
it works it worked in uh you know in
China when we remember when I said the
other day I said believe it we're going
to win five rounds and we're going to
qualify and at the end of the day we're
going to be playing on the stage
remember this conversation I did and we
did it and it was a fantastic call to
make you play in the first board at the
same I mean I was worried in the
beginning but then I kind of got used to
it you know honestly when we're playing
against India I knew you're going to be
handling this easily somehow we had to
just start doing that earlier right my
first use of being Capital uh it was
tough but then I can learn you know I'm
learning from a learning I'm learning
but these days I'm I was like a
experience capital I know because it's
also important when Capitan is nervous
it's actually affecting on the girls so
you gotta learn this as well
sounds great Malik it's lovely to see
here again and I love your positive
energy I love having you around and good
luck with the tournament I will be
rooting for you thank you thank you
thank you appreciate it
foreign